مشهد مألوف للغاية في غرب دار
بالنسبة للقطات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي التي تم تداولها على نطاق واسع
الأسبوع الماضي والتي تظهر
جنود الدعم السريع والميليشيات الداعمة وهم يقومون بمضايقتهم وتهديدهم، وقد
تمكنت شبكة سي إن إن من تحديد الموقع الجغرافي لمقاطع
الفيديو هذه ووضعهم في
منطقة أرداتا النائية في إلا عاصمة
الغرب.  في دارفور حيث وقعت بعض أسوأ
الفظائع خلال الحرب الأخيرة خلال
العام الماضي أثناء الحرب
في السودان، استهدفت قوات الدعم السريع أفرادًا
من المجموعات القبلية الإفريقية بما في ذلك
المساليت الذين طالبوا بالدار باعتبارها
أرض أجدادهم التي ينتمي إليها العديد من قوات الدعم السريع.
القبائل التي تدعي، على عكس المساليت، أن
أصولها عربية، ما نحن على وشك أن نعرضه لك
هو أمر
مزعج للغاية، هذه هي أحدث
الصور الخارجة من الدرور، ما
تنظر إليه هو مقبرة جماعية مليئة بأكثر من اثنتي
عشرة جثث، بعضها على قيد الحياة والبعض
الآخر مات بوضوح رجل واحد  يمكن رؤيته وهو
يرمي الأرض فوق شخص آخر على الرغم
من أنه لا يزال على قيد الحياة،
ويمكن سماع رجل خارج الكاميرا وهو يصرخ بينما
يظهر شخص ما من تحت كومة من
التراب وسرعان ما يدفن رأسه مرة أخرى
في الأرض، ولا نعرف مصير
هؤلاء  من غير الواضح أيضًا ما إذا كان
الرجال الذين ظهروا في الخندق هم نفس الرجال الذين
ظهروا في مقطع الفيديو وهم يهربون من جنود قوات الدعم السريع
والميليشيات الموالية لقوات الدعم السريع،
لكنه يوضح أحدث
أنماط
العنف الأكثر فظاعة في
المنطقة.  لقد
اختنقت قوات الدعم السريع عمدًا، وكان من
الصعب للغاية فهم
ما يحدث بالضبط هناك. قبل بضعة
أشهر، سافرنا إلى مخيم للاجئين
في أدري تشاد حيث تمكن الناجون وشهود
العيان من هذه الهجمات الوحشية من
عبور الحدود واحدًا تلو الآخر،
وتقدم الناجون الشجعان راغبين في ذلك.  للمشاركة
لتوثيق ما حدث
لهم يصفون من مدينة العلا
قصص الاغتصاب
والاستعباد من داخل عائلتنا
فقدنا أكثر من 40
رجلاً قالوا لوالدي
سنغتصب ابنتك أمامك مراسلون بلا
حدود  قال اتركوا هؤلاء،
سنجد من هو أفضل لنبيع هؤلاء،
دعونا نغتصبهم، كتاب
التطهير العرقي، هذه هي السمات المميزة
للإبادة الجماعية، أجرت CNN مقابلات مع العشرات
من الناجين وشهود العيان في آل،
حيث تم استهداف المدنيين وحيث
تم بيع النساء من
منازل العبيد هناك  كان جنود قوات الدعم السريع بالخارج
وقاموا بضربي حتى أجبروني على
دخول المبنى بالداخل، رأيت تسع أو
عشر فتيات بعضهن بدون
ملابس، أخبرونا أنهم سيبيعوننا
بسعر رخيص جدًا، قالوا سنقتل جميع
الرجال ولن نترك أي جلد أسود
هنا.  قالوا
إنهم سيكونون الوحيدين الذين سينامون
معنا لأنه إذا كان لدينا أطفالنا
فسوف ينتقم أبناؤنا في يوم من الأيام.
تمكنت من الفرار ولكن تم القبض عليها مرة أخرى
ونقلها إلى مكان مختلف حيث
تعرضت للاغتصاب مرارًا وتكرارًا ولكن  الأمر لا
يقتصر على النساء فقط، مهدي الذي يبلغ من العمر
16 عامًا فقط، اختطفته قوات الدعم السريع مع
شقيقه وأجبر على العمل في
مزرعة.
[موسيقى]
شهادة
لا يعرف ماهي المبلغ الذي اشتروه
به، لكنه نُقل في النهاية إلى
موقع آخر حيث أُجبر على
العمل، ويقول إن شقيقه الذي أُخذ في
نفس الوقت قُتل على يد
قوات الدعم السريع بعد أن أخبر الناجي شبكة CNN كيف
أن  تحدثت مراسلون بلا حدود عن محو
المساليت المنحدرين من أصول أفريقية، وهي أرض أجداد المساليت في
الدرور، حيث تحتل قوات الدعم السريع حاليًا
جزءًا من كتلة أرض خصبة كان
قائد قوات الدعم السريع
يتطلع استراتيجيًا إلى تأمينها على مدار
العشرين عامًا الماضية مما أدى إلى تغيير التركيبة السكانية
من إفريقيا إلى أخرى.  سي إن
إن العربية
لندن